when when covet hit it was fun to sit
back and watch the leadership reactions
um of organizations and it was inspiring
to see that whether people were good
leaders or bad leaders where they were
effective or ineffective prior to covid
they all most of them lean back on their
own Humanity you know where it was
normal for people to pick up the phone
and say are you okay is your family okay
we had more patience you know if
somebody was struggling and their kids
were struggling or he had a sick family
member we we were okay you know we sort
of allowed them to take time and and for
me the the joy in that was that's just
good leadership you know it's a shame
that it took a pandemic for people to
learn how to care about each other and I
really hope that those skills that
people use naturally uh continue after
covet sadly I'm sure a lot of them will
will forget
um and uh you know a lot of it's just
what I consider good leadership I uh
ideals happened organically so another
one was I talk about this idea of the uh
the um the worthy rival
so I don't believe in the sense of
competition you know we live in a world
where there's no such thing as winning
business it doesn't exist right
um uh where two organizations who sell
basically the same product for basically
the same price basically the same
quality can both be wildly successful
simultaneously you know there's no
winning and so when companies talk about
their competition to me it doesn't make
sense because competition a competitor
is another player you want to try and
beat which means you spend too much time
focusing what they're doing
and you spend too much time comparing
arbitrary metrics whether it's profits
or revenues or market share or number of
properties or number of employees or
number whatever it is they're arbitrary
you get to pick what you're making the
comparison and you're all proud of
yourself when you win at the end of the
year but the game doesn't end
um I prefer the concept of a worthy
rival
and a worthy rival is another
they may they may or may not be in your
industry but it's another player in the
game who does one or many things better
than you in other words their strengths
reveal to you your weaknesses
and you can study them you can be
grateful for them but try and competing
against them is is pointless
um but the whole idea is that the the
only true competitor in the game of
business is yourself how do we improve
what we're doing and learn from those
who do similar things to us rather than
trying to beat them and one of the
things that I saw in covet struck which
I found so fascinating is everybody was
so preoccupied with their own Survival
that the total number of companies that
had any kind of presentation about our
competitive threats was Zero nobody was
worried about their competitors because
they were just trying to survive well
that's correct that is the right
mentality in a good Market or a bad
Market which is uh how do we even if
times are good how do we survive for 50
100 150 years rather than how do we
maximize this year and then and then
blow all the wealth at the end of the
year you know
um uh so I I that some of those things
that kovid sort of revealed are really
good leadership skills that I hope I
hope
stay Way Beyond kobit